well it happened in fourth grade I hit
the project on why is Detroit why was
Detroit the center of the vehicle
industry this is a fourth grade project
I remember I was a group project and I
enjoyed it tremendously and I didn't
know when an economist was in fourth
grade but I knew that I wanted to do
something like that and so from that
time on I you know sort of focused on
things related to business and economics
so I kind of remember that day and I
remember that project and I remember how
much I enjoyed it and I thought I was
good at it I thought I had insight and
so from that day forward I was headed
towards being an economist
yeah I do I think it's not taught
properly at high school if I were
teaching in high school I focus on
personal finance issues you know I when
I got asked out of high school I could
make a pretty good omelet but I didn't
even know what a mortgage was and I
think that's a mistake in I think that's
one of the reasons why we're in the mess
we're in why all those millions of bad
loans were made because people really
did not truly did not understand what
they were getting into so I think the
high school curriculum should change and
Home Economics should be more about the
economics than the home I think that'd
be my view and then I think in
universities it tends to be the teaching
is sort of moved towards the highly
theoretical very mathematically oriented
and it kind of loses touch with reality
what's happening really in our economy
in the real world and i think that's to
the detriment of the profession and it's
a relevancy to you know our everyday
life so i think it's important that
universities at least make an effort to
get back to more practically oriented
kinds of economic analysis or at least
doing economic theory that they can
ground in terms of into something that's
practical oh I think we've lost that or
losing that and there are very few
economist that really can step out of
the theoretical world and really make an
impact on what's happening to every two
people's daily lives
well right now what keeps me at night is
the fact that businesses seem to be
still very not panicked but they're very
very cautious unusually cautious and I
guess it's understandable because many
business people suffered near-death
experiences in the last year and are
just aren't stepping up in longer they
wait to step up and begin to invest and
begin to hire the more likely this
recovery that we're now in unravels back
into a recession and if we get back into
recession I don't think it's going to be
easy to get out people's wages will
start to decline will will be engulfed
in the deflationary cycle we've already
used up most of our policy ammunition
the funds rate target is at zero and we
have a 1.4 trillion dollar budget
deficit so we have to guard against that
and it worries me that that businesses
haven't gotten her groove back at least
not yet